this time in three years it's not  Gonzaga number one team in the country  north Carolina everything is in place  for them to be the number one ranking  Gonzaga number two because they got Drew  Jimmy back gonna be a first  female-american compete for the national  Player of the Year honor Houston  Kentucky failure five raiding national  champs tied for five in Kansas I kind of  feel like Baylor's a little high I like  Kansas the Big 12 is potentially up for  grabs seven Duke new head coach John  Shire taking over for Mike chesky UCLA  at 8 Brayton picking up a yeast at nine  Arkansas ten if there's one team that I  definitely have in my top 10 it's  Indiana